[Applaudissements]
on en a parlé hier yann nouvel épisode
de derrick rose a dit qu'on regarderait
d'erika lors des rixes et cusset sur
france 3 on adore mais on le disait il
ya des cousins de syrie qui sont un
petit peu dans doublage est vrai et
c'est vrai qu'on voudrait filer un petit
coup de main à derrick donc lâché pour
le redynamiser
mais pour le redynamiser sa sera derrick
may du vraiment du tri sud de
l'allemagne quoi à regarder nouvel
épisode aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bon derrick on en est où pour ses
demandes au lancement côte moi j'en peux
plus de cette rançon or ils ont demandé
plus 10 pour ça en plus va pour ça
maintenant c'est quoi +30 plus qu'un
euro plus 50% qu'est ce que c'est
vraiment trop si ces jeux web et 9
ballons de jeunes est d'accord c'est
pour ta gueule l'acompte arras ses noces
et d'eric j'ai une faim sa mère c'est
lui les garçons qu'est ce que je sais
aujourd'hui salut princesse mais nous
trois boulettes à ça marche si mr
victime s'appelait jungen elle a reçu
comme ça on est d'accord pour écoute
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je digère pas les
boulettes je file sinon je vais me fier
tueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez ça toute la journée du matin
sur la bcge pourrait persuader koala
pendant une heure regarder à vrai dire
il comme ça